bonjour limogé bonjour mozilla merci
d'être avec nous dans son crédit ce
matin vous êtes de la cgtm de mai louis
maugée nous serons le 5 février 2019 il
ya dix ans il y avait ce soulèvement ce
soulèvement social sociétal chine aux
antilles ironie de l'histoire les
français se sont soulevés massivement
ces derniers temps d'une autre façon
avec des revendications bien similaire
la vie chère autre similitude les
autorités qui veulent de débats
l'histoire finalement louis maugée c'est
un éternel recommencement
oui absolument je crois que les peuples
ont moins dans leur conscience
collective
l'idée que pour défendre leurs intérêts
ils ont à se mobiliser
qui mettre debout il faut qu'ils
marchent et en france et bien comme
ailleurs d'ailleurs mais c'est comme ça
que les choses se font non en 2009 nous
avons fait valoir notre droit à la vie
une vie meilleure à une vie plus
décentes et bien en france aujourd'hui
le gilet jaune pour la même chose et
c'est tant mieux ouais mais pour quel
résultat
pour quel résultat mais vous savez tout
n'est pas matériel dans la vie ils
prennent au moins conscience qu'ils sont
en capacité de le faire reculer
ne dites pas pour quel résultat parce
qu'il ya quand même le résultat de la
loi de décembre 2018
concernant toutes les mesures sociales
qui a donné lieu à une prime pour le
pouvoir d'achat
d'ailleurs nous envisageons d'exiger ici
qu'il y ait une négociation collective
puisque lorsque monsieur lacroix puis
cette décision parce qu'il avait le feu
un petit peu aux fesses il s'agissait
pour lui déjà dans un premier temps de
demander aux patrons pas en mesure de
prince de donner cette prime qui va
entre 500 et 1000 euros et après donc à
compter du mois de janvier une
négociation doit s'établir dans les
branches professionnelles jusqu'au mois
de mars pour que cette prime soit servi
aux gens
donc les gilets jaunes ont déjà fait ça
donc il ya certainement d'autres choses
qui sont sept bonnes choses cette
mobilisation nouveau commencé une bonne
chose cette mobilisation c'est une bonne
chose les gens prennent conscience que
il existe dans la société qu'ils ont
leur mot à dire
vous avez suivi les échanges entre les
maires de nos pays et le président macro
vendredi dernier mais péter convaincu
lorsqu'on a écouté vos réactions à chaud
après c'est après ces échanges de cette
heure il n'y a pas comme moi nous avons
certainement entendu sur les réseaux
sociaux la déclaration du député de la
réunion monsieur ratenon qui disait que
c'était c'était de la fumisterie
c'était de la poudre aux yeux
c'était une farce et auquel les lignes
et les élus nos repas dur ensuite parce
que tout le monde savait que c'était
quelque chose qui était mise en scène
qui était préparé à l'avancé exactement
quand ma fille et mâcon pour les
départements de france s'était mise en
scène c'est organisées par les préfets
les gens savaient déjà lui
particulièrement il savait par avance et
questions qui lui seront posées et ils
avaient déjà les réponses
et puis quelle est la plus belle farce
que sa peau progrès pons en disant que
toutes ces questions ont été posées dans
le livre bleu bon écoute et on était on
était en plein guignols
vous ne lui accordez aucun bénéfice du
doute un président nouveau hors norme
qui fait ce qu'il voulait pour réformer
la france ça a débordé il va à la
rencontre des gens plutôt des merdes que
ça ne vous convient pas du tout non mais
en termes de réformes qu'est ce que j'ai
entendu j'ai surtout entendu que rien
n'a bougé concernant le problème du
pouvoir d'achat de la vie chère
notamment will à ramener la discussion
sur la question du fait de du manque de
concurrence et messas 2009 on l'avait
déjà dit ensuite il a dit qu'il
s'attaque aux 40%
enfin il a dit ne s'attaque pas
directement cette émanation programme
mais il invite les élus à le faire
ensuite la il a dit mais sans six essais
dans un plan 2022 qui l'a conçu avec son
premier mire il a dit qu'il va réduire
les salles il faut pour régler le
problème du pouvoir d'achat il faut
réduire les salariés des collectivités
or justement on sait le rôle social qu'à
jouer les collectivités en termes de
réseaux options de la question de
l'emploi en martinique donc dire que la
monnaie
les sondeurs côté de ces échanges
emmanuel macron vente ira certainement
pas de question qu'il entend soumettre
pas par la suite au peuple via un
référendum ça ça vous ça ne pourrait pas
non plus oui mais si les dessertes aussi
pipi que cc sig rondes débats ça ça ne
nous convient pas du tout nous notre
démonstration que savez ces deux mecs on
va la fermer
et puis nous appelons à ce qu'il y ait
d'autres démonstrations de dunes du même
genre non ça qui compte prononcer la
mobilisation c'est pas la multiplication
des partis terre multiplication des
luttes
c'est comme ça qu'on nous entend et
c'est comme ça qu'il faut qu'on fasse en
2009 n'ont fait la démonstration que
et en capacité de faire reculer le
pouvoir même si pas après on nous
reproche que après mais oui on a tout
perdu c'est à peut-être peut-être parce
que nous sommes saladier jusqu'où nous
devrions nous devrions aller eh bien
nous allons inviter les travailleurs a
répété cette mobilisation là à continuer
la lutte et à avoir confiance en eux
c'est ce qui manque aux gens les gens
ils manquent de confiance en eux et non
notre but c'est de leur donner justement
cette confiance alors la manifestation
de donner la moby la mobilisation de
demain date anniversaire 10e
anniversaire du soulèvement de 2009
ce serait un anniversaire festif triste
on y va à reculons tellement la
déception était grande
non nous sommes contents d'aller
manifester nous sommes contents de nous
battre nous sommes contents de nous
mobiliser encore une fois c'est une
preuve de notre fierté d'être ce que
nous sommes et nous avons bien compris
que le système démocratique qu'on nous
vend à longueur de journée la république
etc
c'est de la fumisterie nous sommes
conscients que lorsque nous obtenons des
avantages c'est parce que nous sommes
battus pour les avoir donc nous allons
effectivement continuer à manifester
ainsi demain nous allons descendre dans
la rue pour manifester pour l'emploi
pour manifester pour les 1800 euros
vous manifestez pour que des
négociations soit ouverte sur la
question de la prise de pouvoir d'achat
pour manifester pour que les 5000
ouvriers agricoles qui sont menacés
aujourd'hui par le paraquat le
chlordécone et le befoza 3 effectivement
mis dans une situation de prévention de
santé
c'est pour tout ça que nous allons
manifester demain vous y avez fait
allusion louis maugée les partis
politiques la création de nouveaux pôles
partis politiques qui prônerait une
nouvelle façon de discuter d'échanger
d'être en contact avec le peuple vous
semblez avoir émis une sorte de
réticences nom fait référence à pays
ailleurs et qui a vu le jour hier
non je n'ai pas de rédiger pas d'avis à
porter de jugement jeudi ses projets
qualité ce n'est pas la multiplication
des partis qui qui fournit à multiplier
les luttes que deux multi marie les
partis politiques
voilà maintenant si ces parties
s'engagent dans ce combat là et bien
nous les accueillons les bras ouverts
nous considérons que les pubs l'année du
peuple se passe dans la rue pas dans les
urnes ni dans les dents
donne dans les hémicycles tout
simplement et vous et notre jugement de
valeur et vous ai cités c'est parti à
descendre dans la rue avec le peuple
les parties sont assez grands pour
prendre leur propre décision de l'isie
mais justement pose la question vous
êtes un syndicaliste vous êtes vous êtes
vieux militant de la cause syndicale
vous avez comme forcément regard sur
l'implication de ces partis politiques
des hommes et des femmes politiques de
ce pays dans le riz mais mon jugement se
porte plutôt sur ce qui se passe dans
mon camp ceux qui s'inscrivent dans le
camp des travailleurs s'inscrivent
nécessairement pour que l'alu triomphe
et que les résultats soient des
résultats qui soit l'émanation des gens
qui se battent des gens ordinaires
c'est ça notre conception de la lutte
c'est ça et il
maintenant si des partis veulent
s'inscrit dans cette démarche là grand
bien leur fasse
nous prenons des luttes nous prenons des
mobilisations et c'est ainsi que nous
voyons le bout du tunnel
alors qu'ils seront quels sont les
thèmes majeurs à mettre en avant en ce
début d'année 2010 9 valoir et de la vie
chère et parler de delà de la santé par
exemple de ses ouvriers agricoles n'y a
pas que ça alors y'a pas que ça il ya le
problème que posent les salariés qui
travaillent dans le secteur de la santé
vous savez aujourd'hui que l'hôpital
l'hôpital public est en est en
difficulté parce que il y à un manque de
subventions à à son bon fonctionnement
eh bien nous appelons justement que de
nos voeux que ces subventions arrivent
on ne peut pas supprimer l'impôt sur la
fortune
et puis en même temps dire aux hôpitaux
représente pas grand chose ces trois
milliards d'années ce qui est fait mais
il n'ya plus les jo face un état des
lieux de la richesse en martinique eh
bien écoutez je vais tout simplement
reprendre les données de lier dogues
qu'est ce que dit li est donc en parlant
des actifs vous avez les actifs
financiers type d'entreprise et active
des familles c'est ce qu'on appelle l'
épargne ailier donc c'est sur le
boulevard du général de gaulle le bélier
domino dit que en 2017
le montant des actifs financiers
collecté 1 martinique s'établit à 8
milliards à 8 milliards qui dorment dans
des tiroirs de l'ihedn en sur le
boulevard général de gaulle alors ni
attaque ça si vous voulez que je
continue je vais vous citer salle
challenge challenge nous indique que le
groupe gbh entre eux 2017
et 2018 sont sonçon sa fortune a
augmenté de 350 pages la fortune est
passé à 350 millions concernant le
groupe des pointes la fortune est passé
entre eux 2017 et 2018 280 millions
d'inscrits à lundi millions à 210
millions il ya de l'argent il ya de
l'argent je fais la convocation de
limoges ils voulaient pas l'impression
que ces grands groupes comme que vous
vous excitez réinvestissent cet argent
caché tout bagage
vous êtes au courant de ce qui se passe
concernant le groupe des pointes à milly
nice en guadeloupe depuis depuis
plusieurs semaines déjà plus de moi des
salariés 2000 unis sont en train de se
battre pour ne pas perdre des avantages
acquis des avantages que le groupe de
potes a remis en cause
voilà un groupe qui fait de l'argent un
qui passe entre 380 et 8e au 383e en
quiche qui passe de 190 millions de dhs
intérêt à 210 millions alors qu'il
faudrait louis bougie qu'il faudra il
fait de l'argent et qui en même temps
dit aux salariés un bon on vous supprime
les primes de transport
on vous supprime les les avantages
sociaux qu'est ce que c'est que ça alors
qu'à chaque société évitons donc les
travailleurs ils ont raison en entendant
ça ne se dira bien il faut qu'on se
mobilise
il faut qu'on se battre parce que nos
intérêts sur contradicteurs
contradictoires vous leur voulait d'une
loi pour obliger que l'argent qui dort
soient réutilisés investis dans
l'économie que ceux qui s'enrichissent
investissent davantage
c 'est ce serait ce qu'il faudrait faire
mais même lorsqu'ils y a des lois je
viens de vous citer la loi concernant la
loi de 2010 de décembre 2018
concernant le pouvoir d'achat qui
doit-être monsieur mâcon qu'il a
décrétée qui devrait normalement
distribués entre 500 et 1000 euros
la loi existe personne ne l'appliquent
bras il voit là une situation dans
laquelle nous sommes et ce sont ces
mêmes personnes qui se gavent 2 millions
à longueur de journée et personne ne dit
rien alors nous appelons la population à
se mobiliser
nous appelons la population à aurillac
et à descendre dans la rue demain et à
faire en sorte que ces gens là non
seulement nous et en nos ententes mais
nos écoutes
merci louis maugée de la cgtm merci d'y
loger d'avoir été ce matin dans son
crédit bonne journée merci de m'avoir
invité
[Musique]